el noreste de Estados Unidos está bajo
el agua debido a las torrenciales
lluvias que han azotado Durante los
últimos días principalmente a los
estados de Nueva York Massachusetts
Maine y Vermont varios ríos se han
desbordado Arrasando a su paso con
carreteras y casas el servicio
meteorológico nacional ha declarado el
estado de emergencia con al menos 13
millones de personas bajo alerta de
inundaciones repentinas en la región
Estos son fenómenos meteorológicos sin
precedentes que siguen golpeándonos una
y otra vez por lo tanto debemos cambiar
nuestro comportamiento como planeta como
país como estado y en nuestros propios
hogares Vamos a continuar con esta
conversación en serio porque tenemos que
saber que tenemos que hacer todo lo que
está en nuestro alcance para proteger a
nuestros ciudadanos
cientos de vuelos han sido retrasados o
cancelados y el servicio de trenes en la
región también ha tenido afectaciones
debido a las condiciones meteorológicas
las autoridades estatales han pedido a
sus habitantes que no conduzcan a través
de calles inundadas siendo esta una de
las principales causas de muertes
Durante este tipo de emergencias en
Estados Unidos
hubo personas que quedaron atrapadas en
su automóvil en menos de un metro de
agua todas esas personas necesitaron
ayuda de los servicios de emergencia la
cantidad de llamadas aumenta por esta
razón haciendo que sea más difícil
ayudar a las personas el servicio
meteorológico nacional ha informado que
se espera que se mantengan las lluvias
durante unos días más y que es posible
que otras poblaciones sufran
inundaciones repentinas